>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I will just say
that this morning I was reflecting
on lectures we had had previously,
and I remembered that probably
about 2003 we had the
author of this book,
The Seashell on the Mountaintop,
Alan Cutler, who's a geologist,
works at the Smithsonian, local
guy, so he came and talked
about pretty much the
beginnings of geology.
And there was an Italian person
who ultimately became a saint,
and that was Nicholas Steno,
which I don't know if people learn
about that in geology classes, but
he was one of the Medici darlings.
And people were always wondering why
on a mountaintop would
you find a seashell?
So he worked on this
and found out why.
And now, of course, three or so
centuries later, we have people
who are going to planets and
doing the same sort of thing,
getting the rocks and other
debris and studying it.
In fact, I was just reading that
we still have the lunar rocks
from the '70s and people
are still studying them
and finding out new things.
So today we are very excited
to have a planetary geologist.
We've had so many astrophysicists.
So this is our second
planetary geologist.
We had one of her colleagues,
Dr. Bleacher [assumed
spelling], back in 2012.
And he talked about the
Desert RATS missions,
which we'll hear about again today.
So Kelsey Young is
pretty new at NASA.
She's been a postdoc
there and now full-time,
and she's got some other
affiliations that she can mention.
So I will just tell you
where she went to school.
People always want to know.
And she had her B.S. in
environmental geosciences
from Notre Dame, an M.S.
in geological sciences
from Arizona State
University, and also her Ph.D.
from Arizona State University
in geological sciences.
So we'll get started right away
and hear what Dr. Kelsey
Young has to say.
[ Applause ]
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah,
okay so I work --
I have a dual affiliation with the
NASA Johnson Space Center in Houston
and the NASA Goddard Space Flight
Center here in the D.C. area.
And I basically work
between the centers and sort
of at the intersection
of the science
and human exploration communities.
I'm a planetary field geologist,
so I study methods and techniques
for conducting field
geology on other planets.
So who I am, what I do, I sort
of just gave you a spoiler
alert on that first bullet.
So I did my Bachelor's at Notre Dame
studying analog features in Iceland,
so volcanic features
in Iceland that look
like similar features we
see on the surface of Mars.
Then I got my Masters and my Ph.D.
at ASU before coming
here to Goddard.
And I recently transitioned
to being full-time,
split between the Goddard
Space Flight Center
and the Johnson Space Center.
So I'm going to be talking a little
about solar system exploration,
the methods by which we do this,
both robotic and man's space flight
to explore our solar system.
I'm going to be talking a
little bit about analog testing.
So integrated field
campaigns meant to prepare us
for sending humans back to
other planetary surfaces.
I'm going to talk about
field portable instruments,
so high resolution tools and
techniques that we use in the field
to tell us about the
geology of an area.
And then I'm going to look forward
to sort of where we're going next
as a human spaceflight community.
So solar system, obviously plants
are to scale, distances are not.
So NASA has been working for
decades to explore the solar system.
We've sent orbiters, rovers,
and we've even sent humans
out into the solar system
to investigate all these
planetary bodies here.
And I just -- I had to leave
Pluto on there [laughter].
And we've even sent an orbiter
out past the end of
the solar system now.
So we've sent orbiters to
every single planet shown here
in this image.
But now we're starting to get a
higher resolution look at some
of the surfaces of these planets
through rovers and, again,
hopefully through sending
humans to Mars and beyond.
So here are all of the planetary
missions that are either
in operation right now or in
development for the future.
Definitely won't go through all of
these, but in the inset in the --
in the box there you see
the orbiters and rovers,
specifically on the Martian surface.
You know, missions that I'll talk
about later are the lunar
reconnaissance orbiter,
which is an orbiter around the moon.
Rosetta actually just ended.
It was a European space
agency mission that just --
that just ended a couple weeks ago.
OSIRIS-REx just launched actually
about a month and a half ago to go
and collect a sample and bring
it back from an asteroid.
So lots of exciting missions right
now that NASA is currently running
and that we have planned
for the future.
Actually, I think about half an
hour ago ExoMars entered Mars' orbit
and actually sent a lander to
the surface, I mean literally
at 11 o'clock this morning.
So there are a lot of really
exciting things happening.
What I work on specifically
is sending humans
out beyond our planet.
So that's what I'm
going to focus on today.
So, of course, we have one example
of sending humans beyond the Earth
to conduct a field geology
and another planetary body.
We have six surface
missions that sent 12 people
to the moon from 1969 to '72.
They were collecting samples
with tools like you see here.
That's Apollo 17 astronaut Jack
Schmidt collecting a sample
of the lunar regolith with a rake.
They actually deployed
surface science experiments.
So, for example, they
deployed seismometers
on the lunar surface
to study moon quakes.
And they used a lunar roving
vehicle, which you can see here
in the bottom of the picture, that
enabled them on Apollo 15, 16,
and 17 to travel even farther
out from the lunar lander.
So I'm going to be talking
a lot about the intersection
of science and exploration.
And I just wanted to
highlight at the beginning,
one mission that I mentioned earlier
that is a prime example
of doing this.
So the lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter
has been in orbit around the moon
for the past several years.
It was initially funded
as a joint project
between the Human Exploration Office
and the Science Mission Directorate.
So it was -- it was intentionally
funded by both programs
to initially select landing
sites for future human missions
to the moon, and then the human
community was going to transfer it
over to the scientists to allow
them to conduct new lunar science.
So I won't go over
all the instruments,
but they're listed here.
But they were -- this instrument
was specifically selected to allow
for this blend of science
and exploration.
So an example here is the
Apollo 17 landing site.
If you look close you can
actually see the tracks
that the Apollo 17 astronauts
made on the lunar surface.
This is the lander that they
actually did their EVA's from,
or extra vehicular activities.
Then, for example, right on the
left is that seismometer experiment
that I told you they deployed.
So you can actually see this
in really high resolution
detail with the LRO mission.
This is an interesting story for
any engineers in the audience.
When the Apollo astronauts
traveled to lunar surface
that actually jet ascend
boosters that crashed
into lunar surface
before they landed.
We had found almost all of them,
could not find the
Apollo 16 boosters.
And through the LRO instrument
package we were actually able
to find the impact crater made
by the booster impacting
into the lunar surface.
So the types of data
products that we're generating
with this mission are something
like what's given on the right.
This is a paper published this year.
And basically this image shows
a blend of multiple LRO datasets
that were blended together
to create a traverse path
for a lunar polar rover that's
going to search for volatiles
in the lunar polar region.
So this right down here is a
permanently shadowed region.
It never sees the sunlight.
We're going to send a rover in
and around those PSR's
to look for volatiles.
And this instrument
package will allow us
to traverse plan [inaudible]
missions like this
that will benefit human expiration.
But again, we always
have scientific drivers
for planetary exploration missions.
These are three missions in
particular that highlight missions
to bodies that humans could one
day go and sample in person.
Of course, we've already been to the
moon, and I talked a lot about LRO.
This is the Mars science lab,
the Curiosity rover that's currently
operating on the Martian surface.
And then like I mentioned earlier,
OSIRIS-REx launched to an asteroid
in September, and it's
going to bring a sample
of an asteroid back to Earth.
So we've made massive
advancement since Apollo
in terms of lunar science.
Like you mentioned, lunar samples
are still being studied to this day.
There's actually a fraction
of the Apollo samples
that we haven't even touched yet.
So we're still getting a lot
of really robust lunar science
out of them, but they've also
raised new science questions
about the history of the moon
and how it evolves in conjunction
with our planet, as well
as the rest of the planets
in our inner solar system.
So the areas of interest
that we're looking at here,
and that human beings
will look at regardless
of the destination they eventually
go to, geology, geophysics,
geochemistry, atmospheric
science, life-related chemistry,
and the search for life on Mars,
and all of these require varying
levels of human interaction.
But all of them would benefit from
the inclusion of a human being
on whatever planet that we
eventually end up going toward.
So like I said, the destinations
for future human missions
include small bodies, the moon,
going back to the moon, and
eventually the journey to Mars.
All of these destinations come
with varying levels of complexity.
For example, the moon is
relatively close by, of course,
and the communications
delays associated
with a mission control center here
in Houston talking to astronauts
on the lunar surface are negligible.
However, when you go to
Mars you can have up to
about a 30 minute round-trip
communication delay.
So it's really important that we as
scientists, engineers, operators,
learn how to operate under
that 30 minute time delay.
Of course, they have varying
atmospheric and gravity conditions.
You see an artist's concept
of a human being operating
around an asteroid.
You would need to stabilize the
astronauts somehow while they were
collecting samples
from that asteroid.
So varying atmospheric and gravity
conditions really have an impact
on how you conduct
science at that body.
And; therefore, developing
flexible technology now in advance
of these missions is crucial
to understanding how you would
even work in these environments.
And at NASA we have a lot
of platforms that allow us
to investigate all three of these
different destination classes
and how you would operate
in them scientifically.
So the journey to Mars.
NASA is all about the
journey to Mars right now.
This is a pretty complicated
sketch that sort of funnels
into how we're going
to get from here
on Earth to the surface of Mars.
So, of course, we have the
International Space Station
in orbit around Earth right now.
I'll talk about it a
little bit more later.
And eventually we're going to move
out to the moon with
the Orion capsule.
Then we're going to use the space
launch system, a heavy rocket,
to get a lot of mass and
payload to the Martian surface
and the Martian atmosphere.
NASA also has the asteroid redirect
mission on the books to go to a --
to go to an asteroid,
bring a boulder back
into lunar orbit, and
sample that boulder.
We also have many orbiters
and landers,
rovers around Mars right now,
including the Shiaparelli
lander from today.
And eventually all this is going
to give us an orbit around Mars
and on the surface to Mars.
And that includes the Mars'
moons, Phobos and Deimos.
That's part of NASA's
journey to Mars right now.
And this whole construct
shows how we're going to build
from Earth to the surface of Mars.
So this shows it in sort of
a different way that I like.
So basically the Earth Reliant
system here, that's ISS, right,
these missions last
from six to 12 months.
Actually three men
launched this morning
to the International Space Station.
So we had one NASA astronaut and
two Russian cosmonauts launch
at about four a.m. to go to
International Space Station.
So these missions can range from six
months right now it's up to year.
Scott Kelly just got back
from his year in space.
So we describe this as
an Earth Reliant system.
Houston, mission control,
is constantly in the loop,
as well as mission control centers
from the other space agencies
that form the International
Space Station.
But eventually we want
to move out, right.
We want to move to
the proving ground.
And these missions can -- were
conceptualized and can last
between one and 12 months and
it's going to lunar orbit.
It's going to complete this
asteroid redirect mission,
and it's all to get us ready
for the Mars ready systems
which will take us
to Mars on the order
of missions from two to three years.
So we need to learn how humans
can survive in space that long,
how we can land on and launch
off of the Martian surface?
And specifically what I'm interested
in is, how you conduct science
from the Martian surface or in
orbit around the Martian surface?
We want to move forward
from Apollo, right.
And right now NASA
is heavily involved
in the International Space Station.
So the International Space
Station is shown here.
It's the size of a football field
and it orbits Earth
every 90 minutes.
So these -- the crew members
on board ISS get a, you know,
front row seats to the
Earth surface processes
that are shaping our planet, and the
processes that shape other planets.
So they're learning
a lot scientifically
about how the world works, how
Earth's surface processes work.
They're observing volcanic
eruptions in real time.
They're observing hurricanes hitting
the coast of the U.S. in real time.
They can see all of this
happening, and what's important,
and what I'll talk about
later is to train them
to observe these processes
and send back lessons learned
to the scientist here on
Earth that study them.
So they're observing Earth.
They're conducting
science experiments.
And they're learning how to survive
in space for long periods of time.
So they study macular degeneration.
How are your eyes affected from
being in low gravity for so --
for so long on the way
to Mars and coming back?
How is your bone density affected?
How's your balance affected?
And what's going to happen when
you land on the surface of Mars
after traveling for
months and need to put
on a spacesuit and go outside?
How is your body going to respond?
And, of course, we're
also heavily involved
in private partnerships
with private companies.
So here's Kate Rubins and Jeff
Williams capturing a Dragon
from SpaceX.
So all of the activities
that are going
on in ISS right now are crucial
in preparing us to operate
in this Mars system and
the journey to Mars.
But the rest of the talk
I'm going to the focus
on actually conducting
science on other planets,
planetary surface exploration.
So the question I think about
every day is, what do we need to do
to get ready to send humans
to these destinations?
And, of course, the big part
of this is test, test, test.
You've got to test, go
back to the drawing board,
redesign, and test again.
So this requires an ongoing
integrated approach between science,
operations, and technology
to understand how we're
going to operate in this way.
So moving forward, I'm going to --
and the things I'm going to talk
about today are integrated
testing and analog,
so these operational
field tests that allow us
to test multiple components
of a system in one place.
Then we move forward to actually
one year on EVA on a spacewalk,
what instruments you need
to collect scientific data?
And then how does a crew need to be
trained to use those instruments?
How are they trained to actually
be our proxy as geologists,
as scientists, to get the
data that we need on Mars.
And all this will hopefully feed
forward into an exploration mission
and eventually NASA's
journey to Mars,
which you've heard me
say already 10 times,
and you can expect it 10 more.
So this is an eye chart.
Don't worry about reading it.
But this is sort of just an
example of the analog projects
that NASA's relying on in the past
and currently moving
forward to get ready.
So, of course, we have
the Apollo missions.
That taught us a lot about how to
conduct science on other planets.
It was with no communication
delay, which were going to need
to test moving forward to Mars,
but it's a really robust way for us
to test science operations,
procedures,
and planetary surface expiration.
We've got the Mars robotic missions.
While those don't have
human beings on the surface
of Mars it's teaching us
a lot about how to operate
under a communications delay,
what kind of scientific
instruments are going to be useful
on the Martian surface,
and how to operate on Mars
with the Mission Control
Room in the loop?
We have the NEEMO missions,
which I'll talk about,
NASA Extreme Environment Mission
Operations, and that's a mission --
do you like how they build
an acronym into the --
it's the most NASA thing ever.
So you have human crewmembers living
underwater for weeks at a time
and operating under
varying communication delays
with the back room.
You've got the Desert RATS mission,
which I'll talk about as well,
and that's a technology development
platform for spacesuits and rovers
that will allow astronauts to
travel farther than ever before
from the landers they use to
get to the surface of Mars.
We have scientific field campaigns.
What scientific instruments
do we need
when operating on the
surface of Mars?
How do we use them?
These are scientifically
motivated campaigns.
And you also have other
campaigns, like for example ISRU
to learn how -- what technology
you would need to mine resources
in [inaudible] on the
surface of Mars.
So I'll talk about a lot of these
for the remainder of the talk.
Terrestrial field testing in advance
of the planetary exploration
mission is nothing new.
I love -- this one of
my favorite pictures.
This is the Apollo 17 crew,
Jack Schmidt, the only geologist
to ever go to another
planetary surface,
and Jean [inaudible] testing
out in the San Francisco
volcanic field north of Flagstaff,
Arizona where we tested the
Desert RATS rovers right here.
This is just a few miles
away from each other.
So this is nothing new.
We need to actually go in and analog
in a relevant analog environment
to test these technologies
and operational protocols
to get us ready for when we're
really doing the real thing.
So, again, eye chart, but this
is just to show these are all
of the analog projects
that NASA's involved
in right now moving forward
toward the surface of Mars,
or the exploration of Mars.
I'll talk about a few
of these right now,
but each one of these analogs
test something different, right.
There's one, HERA, that's a habitat
on site at NASA Johnson in Houston.
That's actually testing
human factors.
So how do you -- how do you figure
out how a human crew is doing
on a long duration spaceflight.
It's evaluating -- it's for the
behavioral analysis folks and NASA
to understand how human beings
will react to a situation.
HI-SEAS is another one.
That's a habitat on the
flanks of Mauna Loa in Hawaii.
They just finished their year-long
mission where a crew was living
in this habitat for a year and
figuring out how they're going
to react in this environment.
Desert RATS and [inaudible]
are on here.
But each one of these analog
missions test something different
that we'll need as a community to
get ready for crew spaceflight.
So what is analog?
What do I mean when
I see an analog test?
This is a multidisciplinary
field test.
So science operations technology
that allows for end-to-end testing
of operational concepts and
hardware technology software
in a real operational environment.
So something where
scientists, engineers,
technology developers
can work together
in this integrated
environment to understand how
to play off one another and
how to develop technology
that fits the needs
of the community.
And what we do, as a community,
and we do it in the
scientific community,
and we do it in the crew spaceflight
community, is to evaluate objectives
that map to specific needs and
technology gaps in the community.
So if a spacesuit engineer
wants understand how
to build a suit that's going
to allow a field geologist
on another planet to bend
down and pick up a sample,
we need understand that, right.
We need to speak each other's
language and talk to each other.
So these analog missions are
designed to meet those knowledge
and technology gaps
in crew spaceflight.
And this has benefits
across crew spaceflight.
So ISS, what we're doing now has
direct benefits to the crew --
the six crew that are
on ISS right now.
And then, of course,
this has direct benefits
to moving forward to
exploration EVA.
So Desert RATS, this is the
first analog mission I'm going
to talk about.
Here's the Desert RATS
2010 family photo.
So you've got two habitat
rovers that link
up to a habitat laboratory, assuming
that you have a long duration stay
on another planetary surface.
So Desert RATS are the
research and technology studies.
We love our acronyms.
Consist of an integrated team
of engineers and scientists,
including a lot of NASA centers,
other agencies, military academia,
private partners, students that came
together for a couple weeks a year
in the desert to test
technology like this.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about the technology and sort
of lessons learned moving
forward from these D RATS tests.
So we have this habitat rover.
These are designed to support a crew
of two for long duration traverses
on other planetary surface.
So specifically in the Desert RATS
missions each rover contained a crew
of two, one astronaut
and one field geologist,
again trying to teach each other,
how to talk to each other,
how to work together.
Here's a view from the front seat.
The astronaut would sit here,
the geologist would sit here,
and they would drive the rover
with this panel controls
using a joystick.
And then we do EVA.
So here I am with Stephanie
Wilson from JFC.
We'd go out and we'd three
or four EVA's per day,
designed to collect samples and
interrogate the geologic history
of the San Francisco
volcanic field in Arizona.
We had sample collection
technologies.
So believe it or not, these tools
that were mounted on the back
of the rover were modeled
directly from the Apollo tools.
They started there, right.
It worked for them, right.
So we're going to build forward from
this Apollo sample collection suite
and learn what's needed,
what do we need to change.
We're actually doing this on Mars,
going back to the moon asteroids.
And then the final
thing that we tested,
specifically in 2010,
was the habitat lab.
So you could actually dock
to the side of this lab.
You could -- this sort of popcorn
top on the top is where we slept.
So you -- there was also a
geologic glovebox in there.
So they had scientific instruments
in the glovebox that you could reach
in and manipulate the
samples that you collected
on traverse inside that habitat lab.
And so the test, test, test,
test, redesign, test again,
that whole philosophy really
came through in Desert RATS.
So you would test one.
You would meet all year
to discuss how you --
what modifications you needed
to make to the hardware,
and you would come back with
a new iteration to test.
And in this way we really
made these giant strides
because we were working together
as scientists and engineers
to understand what the
other community needed.
And if I'm a scientist and I want
to moon, right, I want it all,
the engineer is going to say
that's just never going to happen.
You need to come to grips with that.
So it's learning how to interact
with each other and build forward
from the previous year's iteration.
We also tested operation.
So integrated EVA science
operations.
That's something I think
a lot about, right.
And that's the same idea
we've been talking about.
Scientists want to accomplish a set
of scientific objectives on EVA.
The EVA engineers and
operators are responsible
for keeping their astronauts safe.
So it's understanding how to
work together in that framework
to accomplish your
scientific objectives.
So in RATS we were examining
the operational concept --
the operational concepts to
understand that interaction.
How does mission control, working
through a science back room,
and the astronaut crew
interact together
to accomplish your
scientific objectives.
We modify procedures
for sample collection.
This is a screen grab from one
of the interfaces we had as crew.
One of the cameras is mounted on
our shoulder to understand how --
once you say I want that rock over
there, how do you go from getting
that rock over there to
a rock that's packaged
and curated for return to Earth.
There's a lot of steps.
I can tell you it's a big time every
time you want to collect a sample.
So it's understanding how to
streamline those procedures.
So sample collection
doesn't take so long
and fits into that EVA timeline.
We have crew training, too.
A real benefit of this was bringing
these astronauts out in the field,
sticking them in a box for a week
with a geologist and forcing them
to listen to us talk
about rocks, right.
So it's a really good way to
train the crew to get excited
about geology, to understand
geology, because they're the ones
that are going to be
doing it one day.
So, of course, we have
science objectives.
So, like I said, we were operating
in a volcanic field
north of Arizona.
Here's a geologic map produced
by the science team for RATS
in the weeks leading
up to the mission.
They use this geologic map
created from aerial images
to develop the traverse
plants for the rovers.
And then, of course, we get
there, we go boots on the ground,
and we say, no, no, no,
and it's all about refining
that geologic map created from
data that's just not as good
as what's available
to you on the ground.
And again, we picked this area
because it's a really
good analog site
to sites we see on the moon in Mars.
So understanding more about how this
volcanic process shaped the region
will inform us about similar
processes on the moon and Mars.
And, of course, we were
collecting samples.
We were geologic mapping.
We were answering terrestrial
science questions
about how the area formed and
in what area were these flows
and cones placed on
top of one another.
And then this, you know, all these
Desert RATS missions didn't just --
I mean, they did end.
We're not taking the rovers
out to the desert anymore,
but we're still getting a
lot of really robust science
and operational information
out of them.
So new follow-up science.
I got back just this
weekend from a trip
to the Desert RATS
field sites designed
to understand the geophysical
properties of the area.
So we're still using what we
learned years ago to move forward
to understanding surface processes.
Moving on to NEEMO, NASA Extreme
Environments Mission Operations,
conducted in the Aquarius Reef Base
sunk several miles off the coast
of the Florida Keys.
A crew of six lives underneath the
water in ARB and conducts a series
of EVA's every day for, in
this case, a 16 day mission.
We just completed NEEMO 2.
So we've run -- we've
run 21 of the things.
NEEMO 21 was run in July
and August of this year
and we completed a variety
of exploration EVA
as well as ISS tasks.
We had an international crew.
We had people from NASA.
We had two NASA astronauts as well
as ESA, European Space Agency,
participation, as well science
PI's who served on the crew
to help the crew understand how
to conduct those scientific
experiments.
And so we had back room support
from, you know, across NASA,
across European Space Agency,
DOD research institutions,
as well as university
and industry partners.
One of the -- one of the pictures
I like from this mission is Matias.
He's from the European Space Agency.
And what you see him doing there is
working with the mini DNA sequencer
that Kate Rubins just ran on
International Space Station.
So they were finding
the procedures and ISS
that Kate would eventually
use on ISS
to sequence the first DNA in space.
So science objectives.
We were conducting coral nurseries.
Actually the EVA and one of the --
in the first week of NEEMO
we can constructed --
the astronaut crew constructed
the deepest ever choral nursery
in the world.
So they conducted -- they
constructed coral nurseries at 50
and 90 feet where they basically
would put these tiny little cards
with coral samples on them
to understand how these
different species of corals grow
at different depths so we
can repopulate damaged reefs
around the world.
We were doing follow-up science from
NEEMO 20, which happened last year.
So we were understanding how
these corals have evolved
in the year since we last saw them.
And we're doing new science.
We are exploring new areas in the
area around the Aquarius Reef Base.
Operations, again, this
is a complicated chart
but it's one I spend a lot
of time thinking about.
So integrated EVA science
operations.
How do you work with
astronauts on EVA, any astronauts
who might be the habitat and not on
EVA who are there to support them,
any sort of mission control
room focused on astronaut safety
and mission operations, as well
as the science back room who wants
to accomplish science objectives?
It's a very complicated
communication pathway,
and we need to understand who needs
to talk to who and when and how.
So that's one of the sort
of operational constructs
that we specifically
were testing at NEEMO
and we learned a lot this year.
We still have a ways to go.
So we were testing
operational concepts
of navigation, traverse planning.
What if you're an astronaut,
you see the traverse plan
that someone drew up, and
they get there and they say,
this is not where we
want to go at all.
You told me to go left,
but this coral colony
that looks really interesting
is over to the right.
How do you react to that real time?
Is mission control going to be okay
with you going right
instead of left?
We need to understand
how that framework works.
We tested a couple other
things that I won't dwell on,
but we tested a new version of
optical communications as well
as actually using a remotely
operated vehicle underwater while
on EVA.
We also tested new technology.
So this is a cue card
with an underwater iPad
that the crew could use to
navigate while they were underwater.
We tested an IV support
system, inter vehicular.
So if you're the crew member
supporting your crewmates while
they're on EVA, what do you need?
What architecture do you
need to help them out?
And we're also building
new science sampling tools
and this geology sampling kit.
We tested this over a series of
NEEMO missions and how do you sample
in this sort of lower
gravity environment?
So next thing, now that I've talked
about analogs, I want to sort
of narrow the focus
to talk specifically
about scientific instruments.
So if you're a scientist astronaut
on EVA, you want to collect samples,
you want to interrogate the
landscape, what do you need
in your hands to do that?
So Apollo astronauts, of course,
had basic sample collection
technologies,
like the rake I mentioned earlier.
But in the several decades since
Apollo we've come a long way
with In-Situ analytical
technologies.
One instrument I spent a lot of time
with is this portable spectrometer,
an x-ray fluorescence spectrometer
that in 60 seconds can give you
the chemical composition of a rock
that you're pointing it at.
So the goal of any instrument
that we're talking about here is
to maximize the science return
of the mission and to increase,
or at least not detract
from, the efficiency
of real-time service operations.
So every time you pull out that
instrument it takes time to decide,
I want to use it, I want to open
the box, I want to pull it out,
I want to it turn on,
I want to calibrate it,
I want to take the analysis.
So every time you're getting
that science value added
to the mission, it's
an operational hit.
So understanding and developing
instruments that fit this need
of increasing science and adding
science to your mission detracts
from your operational timeline.
So we really need to
understand this interplay
and understand what instruments
are worth to include on EVA.
And these instruments, they
influence sample collection.
So if I have 10 rocks in front of me
and mission control is telling
me I can only bring five back,
I need a way to high grade that
sample suite and select five
of those 10 samples to bring back.
These instruments can
help us do that.
And they can also help us understand
real-time In-Situ what we're seeing
in front of us.
As a geologist,
having high-resolution information
real-time is incredibly helpful
to me to understand the
geologic history of the region.
And I can pretty much guarantee
you that that's going to inform --
instead of going over there
this data is telling me
that maybe I actually
want to go look
at this problem over here instead.
So it influences sample collection,
as well as your real-time
traverse they are conducting.
So that way that we're doing
this, that I'm participating
in these activities, is through the
SSERVI Institute, more acronyms.
I spelled it out for you here.
So it through the Solar System
Exploration Research Virtual
Institute, and that's jointly
funded through the human exploration
and the science communities, because
they recognize that there's a lot
of overplay here and we need
to understand each other
to develop these types
of instruments
and operational concepts.
So they fund -- one of the teams
that they fund is the RIS4E
Team that I'm funded under.
The Remote In-Situ and
Synchrotron Studies
for Science and Exploration Team.
And so RIS4E has a really big
scope, and it's basically focused
on what do humans need
in general to get us
to conduct surface
exploration on other planets?
I work on a piece of RIS4E
and that's understanding
field portable instruments.
So I'm going to talk to you about
what RIS4E team is doing in terms
of this portable technology idea.
So here's sort of our
mission statement.
Here are the methodologies
that we use.
You start with a science question.
Of course, right.
I'm a geologist.
I like to start with
the science question.
So you go to a field site, in this
case this is the December 1974 flow,
the Kilauea Volcano on
the big Island of Hawaii.
You start with the science question,
and then you identify, hey,
what are the portable instruments
that in an ideal world I would have
with me when I go do
fieldwork here on Earth
that will help me answer
this question?
Are there any?
Is this a question you even
need instruments to answer?
But if it is, what are
the right instruments?
So we evaluate, we answer
that science question.
We evaluate what role
those instruments played
in helping us answer that question.
And then we -- and in the spirit
of the human exploration side
of the house, feed
recommendations forward for how
to operate these instruments
and what technology needs
to be developed for planetary
surface exploration designed
to answer science questions
like these.
So here's our sort of operational
strategy that we used last year.
We're actually going out
again in a few months,
but this was from a May
2015 deployment next
to the December 1974 flow.
So we have a crew of three.
We had two geologists and one
astronaut on our crew that year.
We had a variety of
instrument teams.
I'll show you the instruments
on the next slide,
but each of them were responsible
for a specific instrument.
And then the unique thing about
RIS4E is that one of our goals is
to work with science
journalism programs.
So Stony Brook University actually
has a science journalism program
where they educate
undergraduate students
about how to report about science.
So we actually in the semester
leading up to the field deployment,
we had them down at NASA Goddard
so they could see what a
NASA center looks like.
I went up to Stony Brook and gave
a couple lectures to their classes
about what it's like to do
fieldwork, what the goals
of our field project were.
And then they came out in
the field with us and we --
each team, each instrument team
in the crew had a science
journalism student embedded with us
that followed us around with a
video camera and asked us lots
of questions and learned
what it was to do science.
So that was -- that was a
really interesting aspect
of the RIS4E project.
So here's our field site.
This is the big Island of Hawaii.
The five volcanos that make
up the big island are
highlighted here in yellow.
Our field site is right down here in
the southwest rift zone of Kilauea.
You can see the December
1974 flow here.
It was erupted from these little red
lines that represent the fissures
that dumped out all of the -- all
of the magma that made this flow.
And you can see the flow flowing
down here toward the
ocean, which is down here.
One of the interesting
things about this site is
that if you see this sort of
hazy, white plume right here,
that's actually the active plume
from the Kilauea called
[inaudible] on the big island.
So the plume is floating, you
know, right above your head
and when it rains it sort of pushes
that plume down on top of the flow.
So it creates some really
interesting alteration products
that we were looking
at with the RIS4E team
and with field [inaudible]
instruments.
So here's a view from the ground
on the December 1974 flow.
You're standing looking up
slope toward the caldera,
so that sort of reddish-brownish
smoke is actually
that plume coming up
out of the caldera.
And this is what the
flow looks like.
So it's a great analog environment.
It's actually in the Kahu Desert.
It's a desert environment that has
brief damp periods when it rains.
There's alteration on that flow.
You can kind of see sort of whiter
products on this darker flow,
those are actually
alteration products that result
when this plume interacts
with the surface of the flow.
And it's a -- and it's a great
analog for other planetary surfaces
because you have these traditional
basaltic lava flows that intersperse
with basaltic ash,
basaltic sediment,
that's reworked lava flows, sort of
scattered in and amongst each other.
And it's got this really
low slope flow morphology,
which is pretty similar to a
lot of areas we see on Mars.
So here are the instruments
we had out with us.
I won't dwell on them.
We had sort of a broad
field of view instruments.
So if you, you can imagine
you're an astronaut driving
up to your EVA site in a rover and
you have cameras and different types
of field-of-view instruments
that you're going
to initiate from inside the rover.
And that includes multispectral
imaging, which tells us
about the composition of the
surface of the [inaudible].
You have LIDAR, which is
an instrument designed
to map surface texture.
Then we had ground
penetrating radar,
which probes the subsurface
of the lava flows.
We had this handheld spectrometer,
that I mentioned earlier,
as well as a different
type of spectrometer
that gives you mineralogy
or other information
about what builds the rock,
what the rock is made out of.
And then we actually had a kite out
with us to provide airborne images.
That image I showed a couple
slides ago actually was taken
from a camera mounted on a kite.
And the reason we did that is
because it's really hard fly UAVs
right now in National Parks, right.
So a kite is a good way to say --
to sort of work with the park
service a little bit and, you know,
it's a way for both of
us to get what we want,
and we got some really
spectacular images with it.
So I bet you thought you were
going to make out of this topic
with no squiggly lines, no can do.
I'm a geologist so I have to
show at least one squiggly line.
And I won't dwell on it.
The purpose is just to show the
types of data that we're getting
in the field so you can
understand what I'm talking
about when I'm talking about
data from these instruments.
So we looked at things like the
alteration coatings on the rock.
What are these sort of
whitish coatings made
out of and do they vary at all?
Are they the same across
the whole flow?
If they vary, how do they vary?
How do they change?
And why? We looked at this area,
this -- it's called a solfatara,
a site of hydrothermal alterations.
So if there's any heat
that's sort of left
over from this continuous volcanic
activity it can alter the rock
and change the composition
and the texture.
We also looked at flow
morphology and emplacement.
I love this image taken with a kite.
And this is actually, this
little dot right here of sort
of lighter material, is actually the
flow that's underneath the December
1974 flow.
So it shows you how
shallow this flow is.
It actually flowed in and around
the preexisting topography,
and you can still see islands there.
And we see this all over
the Martian surface as well.
So these instruments are
helping us to understand --
these are how the -- this is how
these processes work on our planet
to understand how they're probably
working on the Martian surface.
But like I said, there are
operational considerations
of using these instruments.
Going back to the Desert RATS
example, like I said earlier,
while increased science
value is important,
what effects is actually
using these instruments
on EVA have on your timeline?
So the RIS4E experiment is actually
building off these desert rock
timelines understand
how this might work.
So, again, just a quick example.
Again, you just have one
more scientific plot to get
out of the way and
then we can move on.
Here's a geologic map, like I
said, of the Desert RATS test area.
Each one of these black
dots represents a place
where I conducted an EVA
and picked up a sample.
So I didn't take -- these aren't
all the locations we visited
but I just wanted to sort of isolate
the problem to show you example
of how these instruments might work.
So all these places we drove
rover, we got out of the rover,
we picked up a rock, and put it on
the rover to take back to Earth.
So you can see that this flow
right here, this is a really,
really young lava flow, relatively
young, and it looks really different
from everything else around it.
It's a lot darker.
It outcrops differently.
It's bigger and forms these
sort of like big cliff faces.
It's really dark in color.
So you can tell that when
you're a geologist astronaut
on the ground this is
different than anything else.
However, the samples around that
flow look pretty homogenous.
It was kind of hard when you're
on an EVA with limited time,
and we were on the
ground for 25 minutes.
There's just not a lot of time
to stop and think and look
at the rock in front of you.
If you had infinite time
in this area you're probably
sitting in pretty good shape.
But for us we just
didn't have a lot of time.
So what do we need to maximize
that amount of time and tell us
about the volcanic
history of this region.
So the samples around
this younger flow, as crew
and the other crews said the same
thing, they weren't really able
to identify any differences
in these rocks just
in the limited time you had.
And then once you got back into
the rover you lose your access,
you can't see the rocks
anymore, right.
So even if you saw a rock two days
later they are like, you know,
this could be similar to
what I saw the other day,
you can't go back and look, right.
So I went and I took all these
samples that we collected
on our traverse and ran them
through with this x-ray
fluorescent spectrometer
that gives you chemistry.
So, again, I don't need to dwell
on the plots here, but suffice it
to say that the samples
actually cluster themselves
into three distinct groups.
And when you go back and
plot them on the map, hey,
you're able to [inaudible]
three distinct flows.
So you have one flow that flows
over to the west of SP flow,
which is this darker flow.
And then you have a younger one
that comes off to the east here.
And so this is something that
we were not able to identify
in the field just because of the
limited amount of time we had.
But this instrument gave us the
ability to see those differences.
And if we had known that
in the field, who knows,
it might have altered what we
wanted to do with the traverse.
We might've spent more time looking
for more samples from this flow
because we only ended
up getting two of them.
So it might've altered
what we did real-time.
And the hit, the operational hit
to that, every time I decided
to take an analysis with this
instrument it's a two minute hit.
It's a 60 second analysis time plus
whatever documentation, pictures,
I need to do to make sure I
remember where this data came from.
So this just helps you understand,
you know, every time you decide
to use an instrument, and this is
actually one of the lower cost hits
of an instrument that we use.
Some of these instruments can
take an hour and a half to deploy.
So you need to understand how much
science value you get from one
of these instruments based
on the hit to your timeline.
And two minutes, you're
sitting there being like,
she's crazy, two minutes is nothing.
When you're in an EVA suit
and you have, for example,
eight hours to explore this
big area, two minutes can --
they really start to add up.
And the other operational
consideration is
that if you're an astronaut
in a pressurized spacesuit
and you're trying to hold a
spectrometer up to a rock,
that has to maintain constant
contact with the service
of the rock, and you're tired,
you also want to look around.
You're on Mars.
You want to see what's around.
And you're moving your body
when you're doing this.
So 60 seconds is a long time to
-- for me to go up to an astronaut
and say, can you just
hold still for 60 seconds.
So there's a lot at play here.
There's a lot operationally at
play that we need to understand.
So just to sort of sum up
the instrument section.
We know that field portable
instruments are highly beneficial
in both sample high grading,
figuring out what samples you want
to bring back to Earth, and
gaining this real-time insight.
Selecting an instrument
suite is nontrivial.
What instruments do
you want to bring?
I mean, you have this whole host
of instruments available to you.
What's your priority?
What information do you really,
really need and what are you willing
to sacrifice to get
that information?
But selecting this valuable
instrument suite should be a
priority regardless
of target destination.
And whatever destination
we end up going to,
you want to tailor your instrument
suite specifically toward
that landing site area.
And we're still working
to investigate how we'll effectively
integrate these instruments
into future EVA's, but we
need to continue to test
in these relevant analog
environments.
What's also important
to continue to develop,
and this is the last
short little section,
is we need to train the
people who are going
to be holding these
in their hands, right.
This is not the answer
to science, right.
You're not ever going to say --
you're not ever going to have
an instrument that flashes green
for yes, you should return a sample,
or red for no, you shouldn't.
You need to have a crew that
understands how to use them,
understands the data, and geology.
So we're working on
training the astronauts
who will eventually be flying
some of these missions,
and that started back
in the Apollo days.
We say that the Apollo
astronauts had the equivalent
of a Master's degree in geology
by the time they flew to the moon.
They had hundreds and hundreds
of hours of geology training.
They went out on the field.
They were in the classroom.
They worked with the
geology traverse planners
to understand their
specific landing site to know
about the geology they
were going to see.
And we certainly want to do the
same thing with today's astronauts.
So what we do, we sort of
gear our astronaut training
in three specific areas.
We have astronaut candidate
training.
So there's a class astronauts being
selected right now as we speak.
They'll report to the Johnson
Space Center next summer
and will start astronaut
candidate training.
So for two years they're getting
all the training they need to know
to be a certified astronaut
to fly in space.
And one of the modules that we --
that we train them on is geology.
So we go to the classroom.
This is a classroom at Johnson
Space Center where he taught them
about chemistry, mineralogy.
We took them to the
Apollo Lunar Lab.
We took them to the other curation
labs at on Johnson Space Center.
Then we take them in the field.
We teach them how to geologic map.
We take them to a place
in New Mexico
where astronauts have been going
ever since the Apollo days.
Once they graduate from
astronaut candidacy
and they're now a certified
astronaut that's assignable
to flight, we still -- we don't
stop geology training at that point.
So like I said, I just got back
this weekend from a trip to Arizona.
We had Don Pettit out with us
to swing a big hammer and look
at the seismic structure
of this volcanic field.
So we'll embed astronauts from
the office that aren't assigned
to a mission yet within our teams
to teach them how we actually do
geology real-time in the field.
And for, you know, RIS4E campaigns
that I help coordinate, they are --
they are part of the
planning process.
They help us refine our simulated
EVA plans before even get
to the field site.
And we also can have them be
crewmembers on these analog tests.
So this is Kjell Lindgren back
in the 2011 Desert RATS mission,
and he later flew to Space
Station for six months.
So we had him out as a crew
member in RATS embedded
in our science team as well.
So what do we get when we
train astronauts how to --
how to do geology and how
to be interested in geology?
We get pictures like this.
This is a picture of an
erupting volcano in Russia taken
from the International
Space Station.
And it's eruptions like this that
-- this is on a remote island chain
in the Pacific Ocean, we would not
have known this volcano was erupting
if an astronaut hadn't seen it
from International Space Station
and said, wait a minute,
there's -- what's that?
And called down to Houston and we --
because of the pictures that
they took they were ready
for the next orbit when they came
back around, they took this picture.
And scientists are able to infer
a lot about the eruption dynamics
of a specific volcano
with pictures like this.
And it's because we
get them excited.
We get them familiar
with Earth's geography,
and what volcanic features
are in which part of the world
so that they are able to identify
active surface processes like this.
And it's images like this that I
like to think really
get the public excited
about science and excited
about space.
So when we think about this sort
of integrated testing approach
from the analogs, down to
the instrument development,
down to make sure the crew
is trained to conduct science
and [inaudible] on other
planetary surfaces,
all leading us toward an exploration
mission, there are public benefits
as well, not just to the
scientific community at large.
And, you know, a perfect
example of this is, you know,
the Apollo 11 mission, which was
the first time we landed a person
on the surface of the moon.
Here's thousands of people watching
in Central Park in New York,
the parade when they
got back, the excitement
of watching a landing on TV.
And if you talk to anyone
who remembers 1969 I can guarantee
they'll know exactly where they were
when somebody landed on the moon.
And it really incites a lot of
public excitement to be able
to do -- to do things like this.
So another example is just from
October 17, from earlier this week,
we orbital launched
a Cygnus resupply
to the International Space Station.
So here's the picture from
the Wallops Flight Facility
out in Maryland.
Here's a picture I
took with my iPhone
from the balcony of my building.
And I -- you know, I was -- I was
running really late for the launch.
I was really nervous I
was going to miss it.
I was sort in my pajamas
because I didn't expect there
to be anybody else out there,
and I ran up to the roof
and there was a ton of people
up there watching the launch.
It was amazing.
And so just, you know,
people are excited about it.
And I was ashamed that I was shocked
that there were so many people
up there watching the launch.
And, you know, we opened the door to
the roof and we could hear the audio
from NASA TV, because everybody
had it up on their phones.
So people are excited.
And this is -- this is a
resupply going to the station.
I think it's docking with
the station this weekend.
And it's giving them,
you know, what they need
to continue their science
experiments on ISS.
So there's public excitement,
and even more so with all
of the SpaceX announcements about
Elon Musk and SpaceX going to Mars.
So here's a graphic
of the Dragon capsule
that Elon wants to
send to Mars in 2018.
So a lot of these private companies
have also helped incite public
excitement about all of these types
of exciting exploration
opportunities.
So I think -- I'm excited about it.
I think the public
is excited about it.
And it's an exciting
time to work for NASA.
So for that I'll take questions.
>> I'm excited, too.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephanie Marcus: I
think we're all excited,
and what a fun job you have.
I'm so glad that you
could come and talk to us.
I want to mention that
our last lecture
of the year is the Lunar
Reconnaissance Observer,
so you can hear more about that.
And maybe next year
we'll do NEEMO or some
of these other missions
that we've talked about.
So, yes, we'll have questions,
and we ask you to repeat them
so everyone can hear the question.
>> I was wonder how the nursery
was doing one year later.
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah, how the
nursery is doing a year later?
So we actually only constructed the
nurseries in late July of this year.
So they've only been up
for about three months.
And they're going down,
so I actually was a member
of the science team
for NEEMO so I worked
with the coral scientists
who built the nurseries.
And I got my hands on
building these little cards
that you sink underwater.
Coral is sharp by the way.
So they actually go down every
three months to check on them.
So they went down there about
a month ago and they were --
they were thriving and doing great.
So what they're interested in
looking at is some species do better
than others at certain depths.
So they'll go down there and
they'll sort of note down which seem
to be thriving, which
seem to be struggling,
and that's the science lesson
learned moving forward.
>> Thanks.
>> Kelsey Young: Going
on easy on me.
Yeah?
>> So part of the goal for the
private industry is mineral wealth.
Do we know anything about what's
on Mars that could be sold here?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah,
so like what's valuable
on Mars essentially and how to tell?
So a lot of the private companies
aren't really focusing on Mars
for mining, they're
focusing on asteroids.
So they're looking at, you
know, trace elements that are
in really high abundances
on specific small bodies.
On Mars we're focusing more on
In-Situ resource utilization.
So what's there that
humans can capitalize
on to help them survive there
for long periods of time,
and even to sort of like
start to manufacture fuel
to launch back off the
surface and go back to Earth.
So from a mining standpoint Mars
isn't as popular of a target,
especially because there are
planetary protection constraints
to worry about, too.
So we think there could have
once been, or might currently be,
life on Mars, and so the
Planetary Protection Office
at NASA headquarters down the
street is pretty stringent
about what's even going to
be possible in that respect.
So with Mars specifically,
we're focused on capitalizing
on the resources there
to help humans survive,
not as much about mining.
But there certainly
are private companies
who are really excited
mining small bodies.
>> Stephanie Marcus: I think
you were too comprehensive.
I wanted to ask, what
did I want to ask?
These people who were
in the training,
are they going to be
going to the moon?
I mean, they might -- we might not
be going to Mars in time for them?
>> Kelsey Young: So the
current NASA plan has humans
to Mars in the 2030's.
So some of the astronauts who
are currently in the office
and that are being selected right
now could potentially be the people
who are going to Mars
if the plan holds.
Was there one in the
back, over there?
Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
It just takes a long time for
that signal to get back and forth.
And to boost it faster
you need a lot more power,
a lot more bandwidth available on
the orbiters in orbit around Mars.
So just all of the
dynamics involved,
and the engineering involved
at the orbiter end, mean --
make it so that there's quite an
extensive communications delay.
Yeah?
>> This might be a
linguists questions,
but is it still called geology?
Shouldn't it be [inaudible]
something?
>> Kelsey Young: No, I like that.
Should it still be called geology
instead of [inaudible] something?
So like for [inaudible] are
essentially things that are
from far away that are there that
you're wondering how they got there
and what -- and why they're there?
So, for example, [inaudible] from
the Earth's mantle get brought
up to the Earth's surface and --
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, I mean astrobiology is the
common word, or astrogeology.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, true, true, true.
>> What about the Chinese?
How are they doing?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah, so China just
had a big launch earlier this week
to go to their space station.
Yeah, so we don't know a lot
about their sort of long-term plan
to get humans beyond
low Earth orbit.
We know there is one, but there's
not a lot that's really, you know,
we don't work pretty closely
with the Chinese like we do
with other space agencies.
So they are definitely -- they are
definitely hoping to put humans
on the lunar surface sometime very
soon in the next couple years.
And this launch, I think,
proves that for sure.
It was really exciting,
a great launch.
Yeah?
>> Up to now the probes that
have landed on Mars have tended
to avoid the volcanic
regions of Mars.
Now you've been going
to San Francisco mountains
[inaudible] is there any plan --
are there any plans to
send a probe, a lander,
to one of the volcanic regions
of Mars, especially maybe to look
at possible lava tubes and the like?
>> Kelsey Young: Yeah, a couple --
a couple point about that question.
Great question.
So, you know, we -- his
question was, we've been going
to volcanic areas on Earth, but
most of the landers and rovers
on Mars have gone to
non-volcanic areas.
So how do you sort of
remedy that divide?
So we actually do see a
lot of volcanic material
with the Mars landers and rovers.
There's volcanic material
pretty much distributed
over the entire Martian surface.
So it's sort of hard to get
there and not see something
that was eventually -- you know,
at some point derived
from a volcanic event.
But, and also, sort of I
focused for the talk today
on volcanic environments, but I've
also done a lot of field work,
and there are a lot of people
doing fieldwork and other terrains
that we, you know, train
and shape by processes
like what we see on our planet.
Like impact craters, fluvial areas.
So there -- I focused today
on volcanic environments,
but there's a lot of other
work going on to fieldwork
in other relevant terrains.
But in terms of sending something
to a more volcanically dominated
terrain on Mars, some of them --
you know, some of the really big
volcanoes are pretty challenging
logistically to work in,
Olympus Mons for example.
It would really be challenging
from an engineering standpoint
to get a rover or lander there,
but it's certainly a
high-interest target certainly
for future Mars exploration.
>> Stephanie Marcus:
Is that everybody?
I guess we can conclude then.
Thank you so much.
>> Kelsey Young: Thanks [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.